I called the executive producers over to
my house and I told them that I wanted
to come out it became bigger than any of
us ever anticipated I get a telephone
call and my agent sends me this script
and the character breakdown for the
character of Taylor Mason said
non-binary hello I'm Taylor my pronouns
are they there's an vampire it's hard to
talk about without stressing how
invisible gay people were the earliest
representations were always people to be
mocked people couldn't be just who they
were the truth is there was no LGBTQ
presence on TV that I can remember in
1971 we wanted to show people as they
really are it all that time did I ever
mention a woman
it's the first time ever on an American
sitcom that a character came out and
said he was gay that was to me the
breakthrough
[Music]
we were fighting for our lives I will
probably die before I turn 30 years of
age that's how much homophobia there is
in the community
this was the coming-out moment for the
movement on national television this was
the time they first saw us my dad threw
me out of the house the episode airs and
my phone rings and it's my dad one of
the great things about television is it
helps us to make sense of who we are and
where we're going something about being
on television makes people see you as
part of our culture women who looked
like me
could be the centers of their own
universe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you see images that are reflective
of your own life it's a reminder to you
that your life matters
I didn't realize that I was the
revolution that I was waiting for
you
[Music]
you